hello
today we'll look at how we are speeding
up pytorch using torchy a tracing jet
compiler
eager mode frameworks such as pytorch
offer programming model which is way
more convenient than previous generation
frameworks such as tensorflow one
you can just write a few operations and
then print the result which is very
convenient for debugging
but ecomod frameworks are slow let's see
how our example gets executed
when python gets the first operation
pytorch dispatches the multiplication to
the gpu which computes the results
straight away
then the result is passed back to python
again the addition
is dispatched to the gpu which completes
the result and then we are back to
python
and again we go to the gpu and back
to print the tensor we have to transfer
the data from the gpu to the cpu so it
can be converted to a string
as you can see this execution model is
quite efficient
to make things a bit more efficient
frameworks have a bunch of hacks for
example transpose doesn't really
transpose it just creates a view
so in this example changing y also
changes acts and vice versa
one of the reasons to not to not
materialize transposes is that they fuse
very well with matrix multiplication as
metal algorithms usually need to
transpose one of the inputs anyway
another hack is the creation of fused
operations that combine multiple smaller
operations in order to reduce all the
dispatch overhead that that we saw in
the previous slide
but this place is an extra burden on
users to remember all the thousands of
operations
let's now do a deep dive on how pie
torch works we start with tensors
there's a pie torch sensor that lives in
the pibin world which interacts
with a pie torch tensor in c plus plus
a tensor holds a reference counted
tensor implementation
which then holds a storage
implementation
tensor and tensor implementations are
just a view they state how the data
should be interpreted for example what's
the data type what are the
dimensions and so on
storage is the raw data and can be
shared across multiple tensors
this decoupling of tensor tensor
implementation allows for multiple
tensor implementations like dance parts
and so on
let me give you a few examples of tensor
creation to make things clearer
here
when we create tensors from data you
know we need to create new tensors
that's implementation storage strategy
implementation
when you do an operation again we need
to create a new tensor that's
implementation storage solutions
implementation
when you do
in place operation you know there's
nothing new we just override
the storage
2 is a interesting operation so it only
copies the data if
the data types don't match
so
we but if they match it just
bumps the reference counter
for transpose as we saw before it's just
a view so we share the storage and we
just create a new tensor and tensor
implementation
now let's see what happens when you call
a pi dodge function
pythog uses a dispatching mechanism to
get to the right device you can think of
cpus plus v tables for example
the dispatcher takes the hop and input
data types into account to decide where
to dispatch the operation
it also has a global state that takes
part in the decision but we'll ignore it
for now
the dispatcher works in a waterfall way
the first the first handler to match
wins
this handler can either compute the
answer or do something and redispatch to
the next handler
vmapp and batched are used for for data
parallelism
autocast converts some operations from
fp32 into fp16 similar to apex
then we have the tracer which is used by
torchcrypt which we'll discuss later
then gradient computation and finally we
dispatch to a device for computation
it's a quite complex process but it
gives us a lot of flexibility
what's available today to improve
performance of pytorch on a single
device is torchcrypt and the microsoft
onyx ort model which uses torchcrypt
underneath and this shares the same
limitations l shall see in in a second
i've mentioned there's also autocast or
apex
touchscript supports two modes let's
start with tracing the idea is that you
provide a set of representative inputs
so touch scripting executes the function
with those inputs and record all
operations that were executed
it then produces an equivalent function
in an ssa based ir
the problem with tracing is that the
inputs you give for tracing must go to
the exact same branches as any
subsequent call for example this code
from the r item optimizer has four
possible traces depending on the input
values
touchscript only records a single trace
corresponding to the path taken by the
representative input that you chose
initially
if a later input would go to a different
path you get the wrong result as such
script cannot even warn you in this
situation
so this format tracing is quite
dangerous i could as you can get the
wrong result
without even noticing
dodge script also supports compiling
python directly to the same ssa based ir
however the set of python features it
supports is very limited and this is by
design if it supported everything
torchcrypt would be just yet another
python compiler but the tensor compiler
a lot of real-world code bases are just
too pythonic for touchscript it will
never work for them unless people
redesign their whole code to feed the
torch crypt paradigm it's not ideal
so
are we doomed
is pytorch inherently inefficient
and of course not i wouldn't be here
talking to you today otherwise
there's this famous quote in computer
science that all problems can be solved
with another level of interaction except
performance
today i'll show you that even performers
sometimes can be solved with indirection
and this is torchy our new tracing jit
compiler
a fundamental observation that makes
torch torchy possible is that most
tensors are not observed
mathematically speaking
the program on the screen is a function
from two tensors x and y to a to another
tensor the intermediate values of w are
not observed
in fact
chances can can only be observed in very
few cases like for branching or printing
say when you print the loss for example
otherwise most of the time we are just
accumulating operations over temporaries
and this is the key observation
so the idea is to delay execution until
observation instead of competing
operations straight away we accumulate
them in a trace
then when we get to an observation event
we stop and send the whole trace to the
gpu for computation
therefore we save the whole back and
forth to the device
plus we can optimize the trace which is
just a nice little program
tracing jits are not new they have been
a tremendous success for javascript
because of the delayed execution we can
batch operations we can also detect
which variables are just temporaries and
never observed which is good for
optimization
traces can be optimized and this cost is
amortized as traces are executed
millions of times
and best of all tracing jits work with
any code base and modified no code
changes needed
torchy works by intercepting calls in a
transparent way using the pytorch
dispatcher that we have seen before
the program needs just a single line to
enable torchy
which essentially
changes the global dispatcher state to
always dispatch to torchy
we insert torchy in the middle of the
waterfall
instead of executing operation torchy
writes them in a trace and returns a
dummy tensor later on torchy executes
the whole trace either using the
waterfall mechanism or by using
alternative back-ends
these smallly straight-line programs are
the dream of any compiler
pytorch also has some observation events
that don't go through the dispatcher
we have our own tensor implementation to
intercept these events
for example when printing we may need to
force the trace to be
executed
we are in early days so
we have been running just a few
benchmarks from torch vision and and
hacking face
for the sake of curiosity just wanted to
to show you how bird looks like from the
perspective of torchy
circles are traces and errors are jumps
between the
traces
we see that the whole bird model
consists in just a few traces that fit
on this slide
zooming in
i've copy pasted the model diagram from
the paper for reference so we don't get
lost
now we see the individual operation in
each of the traces
surprisingly each trace corresponds
roughly to a building block of bird we
have the embedding layer attention hat
normalization and feed forward
operations correspond one to one to the
internal pi torch operation
also known as a10
and here's the continuation of the model
with more normalization feed forward
attention and then the output
today i've presented torchy a new
tracing jit compiler for pytorch it
works by delaying execution of
operations and batching them onto traces
traces are then optimized and executed
with the best backend
best of all torchy requires zero code
changes even for dynamic models
thank you for listening i hope you'll be
using torchy very soon